you try to convince people in Iowa that
you believe in Jesus and the other gods
have you seen that I the truth man about
my beliefs you're like we believe Jesus
is a Son of God that's Son of God which
is different than saying he's the son of
God and the guy's talking to a
Presidential nominee he goes there's one
son of God I mean look I will respect
there there were there were a number of
people who I met who struggled One
Pastor towards the end of the campaign
and he wrote an extensive post which was
he's a influential pastor and he's he's
a good man but he wrote I didn't I had
met him at this time part of a demonic
cult the way you know the way he
describes Hinduism and and he recommends
everybody vote against the member of a
demonic cult being our US president he
wrote that about you oh yeah it was an
extensive post no but I think those are
the words exact words demonic what's the
justification like well I I think I
think so so so I think people were just
like stay you know stay away from him
you say to him I called him I called him
on the phone said I would love to sit
down with him he came out in the middle
of a blizzard in the middle of a
blizzard he came out and he listened and
we had a deep conversation on the back
of my campaign bus afterwards yeah and
he brought a he's a collector of ancient
books he brought he said it was the most
valued book and he left it with me I'm
still I promised him I would read it and
I would it hasn't been that long since
the end of the campaign but in his world
it's about it's it's a book about the
values that informed American history ah
and it was a signed book by the author
and it's not in print anymore it's an
old book and and it had real sentimental
value to him he then after our talk had
an extensive post on you you want me to
pull it up actually yeah sure I can pull
it up in the case of V if God decides to
use him as a president I will have cause
for joy and certainly support him and
pray for him as often as I have for any
other president but what we are
discussing is whether or not we as
Christians are allowed to reward a
candidate with authority and Power in a
republic
and then it goes on to explain why even
though he agrees with everything that I
say this is ultimately why no Christian
should be permitted to vote for me in
his opinion do you think if you were
white and Christian you'd be president
right now white and Christian would I be
president right now I don't think so I
don't think that was the r limiting
issue so I don't I mean just to I'll
call it like I did I do think it was an
obstacle for me yeah in Iowa I think
that we opened up conversation about
faith at like a level of depth that we
have not and I think the people Iowa and
myself have not otherwise and would not
have otherwise gone into I think many
people elucidated for themselves what
the distinction was between pastor and
president and how they could with
conviction understand that their
religion was fundamentally different
from mine voting for president and for
what it's worth it actually was a
forcing function for me to get to like
okay you say you're Hindu or you say
you're Christian or whatever you go
about your daily business but this
process I think really forced me to
deeply understand what the core
convictions of my faith actually are and
so it was it was very productive in that
sense actually but I think that there
were a small minority I don't your
belief in God yeah actually like what
even the theology underg guring my faith
I think that that was something that I
probably emerged with greater Clarity of
by the end of this campaign rather than
the beginning because it's a very
frequent topic that comes up and so it
forces you to press yourself to
understand I sorry I would love to hear
that and how yeah you change your but
what do that make you ReDiscover is what
I would say how do that make you feel
reading that like this is a guy who's
vote you want he's going at you for your
faith and then the end of it is
masterful Comm all positive qualities I
still will I will never and no one of my
faith should ever vote for this man how
does that [__] the right answer how does
that make you feel so that's what I'm
interested in so I would tell you what
my my first fleeting reaction is what my
total reaction would have been a year
ago which is one of Fury rage
frustration and like maybe a tinge of
sadness and
disappointment because I feel that yeah
okay that's what I that's that's sort of
a microcosm of what my first instinct is
and like I said like that's at the start
of this journey what I would have what I
would have said right now what I feel on
the side of that is then some okay
pause this is a good man actually who
cares so deeply about this country that
he has paused to think about how his own
theology connects to the future of our
Republic I spent an hour with
him and he spent that time because he
deeply does care about the country and
believes that he has a duty to fulfill
in it and for somebody who at least
gives a damn
very all to say it that way but a pastor
I guess it's a little but who who cares
that much
right I'm kind of grateful at least
because I think that he and I probably
share a deeper care for this country and
an understanding of doing what in our
Hindu yeah our Dar would
be than most ordinary people living
their lives and then
over the course of most of my life and
so for that I guess I'm grateful
actually and I think we're going to be
friends I think he's wrong on his
understanding of what the Constitutional
role of the president is and I think if
I may say so he's wrong on even what I
think the Bible will ask of him in to
decide in the way he chooses to elect a
president and I intend to stay in touch
with him and if I do run for president
four years maybe he'll have a different
view by the time that we do and so I
guess that's where I am right now is a
profound respect for his level of care
for the country doesn't change my view
that I think he's just on both the Bible
and the Constitution wrong on this but a
commitment to say this is a guy who I
think I kind of respect towards the late
phase of the campaign there's another
Pastor I went to a church with and some
will happen when you go to these
churches on Sunday mornings sometimes
more often than not to be clear what I
what what was represented there is a
minority view amongst Evangelical
Christians that is not the predominant
view of most Evangelical Christians but
I think it is a distinct and nony
minority so we went to another we went
to a bunch of churches on
Sundays and most of them actually what I
would sense happening I can't say for
sure but you get a sense of these things
is they'll almost soften the message a
little bit
um to sort of be inclusive actually to
make us feel warm and welcome
at the end of a prayer even if they're
praying over us you'll say usually say
the prayer in Jesus name amen and then
you'll also often when we're there we'll
say say the prayer and saying all God's
people say amen and and I I felt like
telling them and maybe I should have is
just like you don't have to say it that
way if you end your prayer with saying
in Jesus name say in Jesus name because
that's what is most heartfelt to you but
occasionally we would actually get
somebody who also takes notice of who we
are and wants to send a message to
everybody else who's in that
congregation and so we went to one where
it was probably the the most pointed
sermon that I have heard but he went to
draw and parse every distinction between
for those of you here who think that you
need to understand the philosophy of
Christ and that philosophy is what
speaks to you and that's what you want
to take away from today you're missing
the point Christ Christ is the way he's
not a path he is the path M and he said
he gave gave he gave I mean it was it
was it was clearly intended that we were
there and the person who brought us was
a relatively prominent person and I
think it was I think he was checking
actually I think I don't think it was
not a rebuke at us I think it was a
rebuke at the person who brought us is
what it was who was a relatively
prominent person and I think it was
intended as a somewhat of a somewhat of
a slap on the wrist or a rebuke not to
say that we shouldn't show up there but
we shouldn't show up there as somebody
who's not actually open to or being
there for the purpose of openness to
conversion well I'm sure he's also
looking at his flock and going wow these
people are running for president and
they want the vote of my flock me
endorsing this man exct is telling all
these but I respect this man but then
then so he started and and once he got
warmed up then then it wasn't even on us
he was just going on he was just going
scorched Earth so he said you know a few
weeks ago I gave a sermon and we gave I
forget which passage it was but it told
the story and there's a gentleman who
came up he said it was my first time in
church in a long time he had tears in
his eyes and I said oh well thank you
for for coming and he said no Pastor I
just want to say thank you you've opened
up something in my heart that I
previously did not have I haven't been
to church in a long time you brought
tears to my eyes and I want to say thank
you for that and he said well what what
did you take away from the teaching and
the man said I'm still processing it but
I can just tell you the feeling that I
have is one of gratitude and the
pastor's speaking in the sermon he says
well I just looked him in the eye and
said I think you might have just liked
the
band and I was just like
it's after he's just delivered kind of
scor SC this bastard I forgot his name
but I but he was I mean it was a I think
we brought it out in him you know
sometimes sometimes there's a situation
and you you awaken your inner Beast yeah
I think this I think and and that was
just I mean he was just going line by
line of people from the congregation
come to him with these lines and he
would just be ripping them to shreds
because people Miss what the actual
ultimate point is is that there is one
One path black dude to God no he's white
my God not that many black Pastors in
Iowa there was
one I mean I don't know you been
Iowa I don't know if you been you don't
say have a flourishing B he was the
black member of the congregation I was
representing I was repres I wear
multiple hats but the uh there there was
a black p probably wearing one Hood
there was a also guys don't forget about
prize picks hurry up and sign up NFL
playoffs is the best time of the year
this is what you got to do I'm giving
you my sing locks first of all this is a
four player thing so it's a four player
pick so if you hit you can to make you
can make some cash off of prize picks
first of all Isaiah Pacho will get more
than 63 and a half rushing yards Patrick
Mahomes will get more than 248 and a
half passing yards Travis Kelce I love
you I love what you're doing with Taylor
Swift but I think you're going to get
less than 65 receiving yards and Lamar
Jackson MVP I think you're going to get
more than 212 passing yards and sign up
for priz pi.com use that promo code
Schultz they will match your initial
deposit up to $100 so you put in 100 you
100 for free